[Music]
welcome let's dive right into it
this talk is going to be really open yet
it just to offer the initial initial
advice for engineering perspective yet
just just consider that it's not
dogmatix or everything is just up to
discussion it's not black and white and
it's based on my experience running a
solo consultancy company for
industrializing data science models and
setting a big data infrastructures this
talk as of now is available at that URL
that you can see so what is talk about
what this talk is about this you have a
model and you want to put it to
production and there are a lot of
conflicting goals coming from the
business that you want to adhere to you
can see a list list in there and from
the engineering perspective adhering to
all these goals can be really
challenging so what I want to show you
is just a list of 20 best practices that
I have come up with which can help to
deliver on these goals and since the
time is limited let's dive right into it
so the very core principle the first one
you have developed a model and you want
to put it in production well most
importantly don't build anything don't
in this trice your code just buy and
off-the-shelf solutions there are
immediate benefits to this from a rapid
project delivery minimum maintenance and
and so on you can all read it on the
left side the there are vast ecosystem
out there for SAS solutions which you
can reuse for example for ETL data
warehouses for a/b testing machine
learning and so on so don't be afraid
and and try them out it will save you a
lot of time however if you really
decide to to go and build something just
start start small built it lean build a
very narrow slice of functionality and
then expand it if you want to learn more
about how to do this there's a great
book lean startup and also there is a
blog post about the the the thirst of
the quench what develop developers have
to which drives them to in to implement
solutions rather than reuse so please we
didn't and go this way well however if
you decide to to build something then
most important how to collaborate and
how to use git what I found is have at
least two people always on a project it
encourages shared knowledge you can
rubber duck with an actual person
instead of a duck it increases the bass
factor so if a person leaves the
knowledge is preserved in a company the
the code quality is higher and it
prevents one main frameworks and over
engineered solutions just by having more
people in the team if this is not
possible then at least add another
reviewer to the project alright what you
want to have a team then just use git
use it as a platform for versioning
collaboration and employment I think of
kid as the centerpiece in all projects
that the whole engineering and
development revolves about using it has
great advantages just on the left side
there are listed there what's also
important get is the usability can be
improved so it might be a bit
unintuitive sometimes what helps a lot
is to invest in learning it use it from
command-line understand the basic
commands and this this really helps
another one once we have kid then just
require public and focused code reviews
there is a great quote from a bus from
github this year on undeb oh my I'll
read it when another person looks at
your code and gives it the same level of
attention like you did when writing it
your work gets better
indeed code reviews helps to catch bugs
way earlier during the review process
rather than when the application is in
production it helps to share the
knowledge and both the the coder and the
reviewer benefit from from this process
how to do this just use dedicated
feature branches which are short-lived
for new features and fixes use pull
requests and merge them only if they are
reviewed and accepted by by your
reviewers if you want to read more about
how this works or how to do Khan reviews
there are two links below alright so now
we have a code base we have a we have a
git and a team and we need to write a
code what helps a lot is to have a clean
code base and I cannot stress this more
enough if I would have to pick just one
principal to take out of this talk is
just this one apply clean code
principles is just number one most
important engineering principle which
everybody should everybody doing any
coding should adhere to it having
clincal just drastically improves
readability it leads to faster back
detection and lower maintenance I
actually had in my university a whole
semester about clean code so there can
be a whole conference or at least talks
about this topic what I really encourage
you to do is grab the book the code
complete and just read it and this will
this will make such a difference the
Jeff and Ruth who is the founder of
Stack Overflow my developer
idle said that he has a list of books to
recommend for each developer and this is
the number one book and he says that
make this book the first to read and the
first book you you recommend to your
fellow developers I cannot stress this
more just to select a very low hanging
fruit from this book there are two main
principles just don't repeat yourself on
any level if you have just the same
literals within your Python code or
one-line functions if you have parts of
the method which are duplicated just
extract this logic and you will see that
this principle is kind of elegantly
driving your refactoring and leading to
better code also as touched in their
keynotes
there's also duplication within the SQL
and ETL pardoning data preparation so
try to catch these and also just make it
make it dry use it only in Internet it
only once don't duplicate and the second
thing is just naming things semantically
so instead of having variables called
data just put some semantic meaning into
them for example sensors instead of data
a reader immediately knows what is going
on and I have a few personal favorite
principles one is organizing code by
features I'm not going to it
take a look so really this is the most
absolutely most important principle when
building something I cannot recommend
the code complete more all right and
then another one is just prefer
immutable functional and side-effect
free code David Pollock who is a creator
of Scala leafed web has this great quote
about function programming I will just
read it
immutable variables leads to thinking
about alternative immutable functional
code that leads to new coding patterns
new coding patterns leads to a shift in
your approach to programming and this
shift in a
approach leads to transformative code
that has fewer defects and is easier to
maintain I always thought that
functional programming is something to
be used in Haskell and this academic
language is when I when I studied the
Haskell wasn't used in industry at all
and it took me a while to realize that I
can what this functional approach really
is and it doesn't it's not related to a
language you can write functionally
mutable code in any language possible
and I very much advocate to doing so in
in Python as well if you want to know
more about this there is a great a
course on Coursera by Martino turski the
founder of Scala about the functional
programming it's language agnostic of
course but you can get the basic idea
what it means in there another one is
use causes consistent code style
oftentimes we are when we don't do this
we are a code in low priority of
linearity discussions and we need to
have a lot of small decisions we need to
do all small decisions while coding and
having a consistent code style helps to
fight this and to lower decision fatigue
so please do another one use consistent
and semantic field names in your data
frames and databases this is such a huge
time saver so I often see you have a
table with what I want to do is just to
have a quick understanding what the
table or a data frame is about and just
applying a few simple principles I'm
able to do so so I just pick two one is
to have a consistent naming so for
example brief just a very simple one
just prefix all fields or boolean fields
with is or has there's really helped and
another one at semantic meaning so
instead of having a column which is
called timestamp what does it what is
the times tonight and I know it's a
timestamp just from looking at the data
but what does it represent
so for example just replaced imported at
or imported that instead of time it
immediately gives more information what
also helps is just to use a strict
sequel schema and strong validity checks
what I mean that in the beginning of a
project try to have s to encode as much
information and into the database schema
as possible which will give the checks
and also the kind of implicit
documentation about the data you are
using and you might find later that the
check is too strict so you can you can
anytime loosen it back the loosen it the
other way around that doesn't work well
if you have a very loose schema and you
want to make it strict then you have to
do a lot of a lot of additional work
test your code especially end to end end
to end test are the killer ones because
what I found is that end-to-end tests
are typically short brief like concise
but they are so powerful it enables to
do refactoring of all the sub units
within a feature and you and it tests
the whole pipeline so they are very
elegant and based on my experience the
way to go and if in this pipeline we
have a complex logic just use unit test
to really
bullet prove them and one which is often
for goddes also test your ETL and data
quality we are on the PI data conference
we speak about a lot of machine learning
models but what is B below them is is
data and having corrupted incomplete
data can lead to wrong results so what I
found useful is at checks assertions in
your in your ETL and three detail part
as as a real code just as you would
treat the code
all right so you have a clean code base
let's speak a bit about the architecture
and to link keep architecture as simple
as possible I've seen this many times
due to different reasons let's say what
sometimes happen that is the top
management goes to a big data conference
and they hear that they want to do Big
Data and Hadoop and they come back to
the company saying team please implement
Hadoop so the team implements Hadoop but
maybe it's such an overkill to do it and
just be aware that there might that
particular technology might be currently
hyped and might be an engineering
overkill to use in your particular
situation what I found is that just
prefer simple bad jobs over real time
and single host over distributed and so
start with batch single host
implementations and move to more
complicated ones only if that is really
needed what this allows is also to grow
your architecture organically based on
problems rather than hype for data
persistence also keep it simple just
consider plain farce or relational
databases as a baseline a deviate only
if if needed as you can see I'm a huge
fan of keeping things simple this also
applies to persistence most data that I
have encountered are not large and have
fixed kheema so why not use a tool which
is perfect in this which are relational
databases it has a many features
powerful features that you can use of
course you might have a very special use
case and your and what you need this is
different from a relational database but
that just always takes in this case
Postgres my favorite one as a baseline
and deviate from it only if
the requirements call for it also there
is a great article you edit at the
bottom the first tip you probably don't
need a dupe just wonderful article I
very much recommend to read it and I
also recommend using Flyway which is a
sequel migration tool for reliable
schema update if you don't know them if
you don't know it please check it out
it's a really really sweet - regarding
building your ETL pipeline I found out
that there are dedicated tools which can
simplify the jobs for you
the for example Apache airflow and Luigi
you don't have to the ETL you have all
these if you build your own pipeline
framework you like it's not hard but
there are a lot of these small things
you have to think about and there are
existing solutions for this so please
check it out and it might be useful to
you another one is just doing a
dedicated job queue management tool for
long-running user triggered computations
for example salary and the API scheduler
um so for example if you want to just
trigger a task which should we train a
model or run an ETL and it takes long
and it can be triggered multiple times
from multiple administrators or
end-users such to my my greatly help in
implementing such use case and the last
part is DevOps setup push-button
deployments Martin Fowler who is an one
of another idols for me says that you
should have ability to perform patch but
push-button deployments of any version
of the software to any environment on
demand and once I came to a company and
was a the deployment process took
actually it was a manual there was a
manual for it it has like 30 pages I kid
you not and if you want to deploy a new
version to production you just have to
pick up this manual and just read it
through and it took maybe a few hours
just to deploy a change so the first
thing we did we fully automated this and
create a created push-button deployment
it has many advantages to do it like
this to have a push-button deployments
because it it encourages you well first
of all you have to have it removes
friction so you are kind of encouraged
to deploy more often because it's so
simple and you start it completely
changes your mindset once you have the
deployment automated what also helps is
regarding deployments to have strong to
have your code base strong backed by a
strong test so you have confidence to
deploy often and once we have these two
things confidence in your application
and automate the deployment pipeline you
are the king really because you can just
you can deploy often even daily or after
each change and your time to market
lowers drastically while keeping the
deployment risk low I like the last
bullet from the house section aim for
boring predictable and frequent
deployments another one keeping the def
test and production environments
identical I see this many times that
there is a you have a you have a some
kind of you have a model which is
developed there is a data scientist
working on Windows using some kind of
binaries using a binary solver let's say
which is installed on a system then I
work on on my Mac and the application is
deployed on a UNIX machine in so there
are three different
operating systems with three different
compiled binaries there many times I see
that there is this work on my machine
problem and you can eliminate this
current there are tools to eliminate
these kind of problems typically
provisioning tools where you can choose
an operating system install system
dependencies and Python dependencies and
have the same environment the close on
my local machine and on production
apart from removing this work on my
machine it also implicitly documents the
system requirements which is always very
helpful it also helps in in running
integration tests in your continuous
integration platform and it also helps
to create just one button setup for
local development environments so if you
have this set up typically then means
that you can have a new developer coming
to the team and with you just do git
clone and the dr. Campos up and he has
the whole you know the whole application
including system dependencies databases
ready seas and whatnot up and running
with run command my favorite is docker
for those of you who don't know docker
they're just a very quick example of its
power on the Left we see a docker file
well when you include you defined where
your docker image which is kind of like
a very lightweight virtual service very
lightweight though a virtual machine you
define from which base image it arrives
from in this case I chose Python 3.6
which did which again derives from I
think Debian you can install Dec you
declare declaratively specify what needs
to be installed on this base image in
this case I have some solver libraries
and then I copy my application to this
docker image and I run the requirements
and I specified that when I run this
image the command Python predicted PI
should run
once this is built you can just kind of
run this container you can think of it
as a process but with encapsulated with
the whole operational operation system
encapsulated within it and you can just
simply run it you first build it with
docker built and then you you run an
image with the dock you run predictor
this is super powerful if you don't know
it check it out
another one is centralized runtime
logging text if you log two text files
these it might be okay but you might
find yourself that it's a very
cumbersome to analyze and cumbersome to
access I encountered both both issues
and having a centralized server for
logging helps helps a lot it if you use
let's say the Alex tech which is my
personal favorite you get a very easy X
you have elastic search on the on the
bottom as a database and you push logs
there by some lock a greater solution
let's say lock stitch and then elastic
search as a JSON database gathers the
log messages and then you have cabana
which is a web UI on top of it through
which you can very easily explore
visualize and dashboard you're logging I
very much recommend it it also have a
custom REST API if you want to build a
custom dashboard or some kind of sleek
sexy slack integrations with elastic
search and stuff like this
another one is use environment variables
to configure and applications what helps
is if you treat your application as a
black box docker is good for it because
doctrina enables you to do it like this
and you can take this black box and run
it in any environment your local machine
or in production is the very same black
box the same image however there are
differences between an
like for example database URLs and
credentials and what I found useful is
to configure these particular
environment specific settings via system
environment variables this allows you to
not touch the black box just set up the
just set up the parameters from the
outside via environmental variables and
run it wherever you want what is great
about this is you can have the same
image running in production and then for
testing purposes you can just run it
locally with just the different
environment settings there's a great
attic article about it at the 12th
factor app it's a collection of best
practices used for developing web-based
applications and in particular this
section about environment variables is
greatly explained there I also recommend
to check it out and the last one is just
u-k's use slack as your information and
control hub I cannot recommend this more
in slack you it's really if you don't
know slag it it's a it's kind of like
Skype on steroids and it allows you to
have a plenty of sleep integrations so
what I typically or within a team
typically setup is just to have
notifications about new commits new pool
requests about successful or fail
deployment about exceptions running
occurring in the runtime some data data
checks about the ETL and business
metrics and so on and also you can add
commands to to slag like for example
merging pull request
or trigger deployment and stuff like
this well and that's it 20 best
practices I hope it helps thank you
thank you so much do you have any
questions yeah we have questions you
have to use yes
oh it's also in the back oh no it's not
here thank you I talked with Marcel da
da / cool PI data workshop conference
2017 another question it's there okay
hey great talk as far as I understand he
used that in your life right yes so how
do you manage secrets actually I have
few more questions that the first one
yeah secrets well first of all don't
commit it in the in your application
code and this is to me the the basic
principle or what you can do is either
store it in a dedicated git repository
with limited access or you can use what
I haven't talked about instead of
environmental variables use like
configuration dedicated services to
store secret information and then you
have your application and you just ask
for a credential from this service you
can use this if you have a more complex
or infrastructure okay actually we are
using ansible vault to encrypt the
secrets but I'm just I'm just asking
because I'm curious how do the people
use another question does the docker
image contains models from machine
learning or this depends on the I cannot
tell depends on the use case okay but do
you feel it's better to include it
inside or maybe store on some kind of
shared volume but because then docker
image it's getting quite heavy to upload
and download and so on so
from the engineering perspective I would
always advise I would advise to put a
model in a docker image because it and
kept its a like a I have this so it's
like a black box with the whole
operating system and Python dependencies
and it's it runs the same on all
environments so from this perspective
put it in a docker image and related to
if the docker if the image itself would
get large there are workarounds around
this you can use for example smaller
base images you don't have to you don't
have to have a docker image based on the
whole Debian distribution you can use
Alpine for example an Alpine Python
images like five megabytes so no issue
there as far as I'm concerned
i I think I haven't a bisect yeah I
don't know how it's pronounced I I
haven't but the colleagues of mine have
and the argument is that the argument of
this slide was should just use git
because of all the powerful features an
ecosystem around it and Plus on top of
it it comes with advanced features which
you might find useful in the in the
future and bicyclists is one of it
now there's one more
works yeah one more but this is the last
one do you have any experience working
with an guard or feature forge for
checking the ETL on pandas let's say
there's two projects for a sort of
testing in production let's say ETL
let's say you're gonna have some
distribution of data coming in your
water model assumes it but you didn't
never implicitly check it so do you like
asserted or you you have an experience
using maybe those unguarded or future
Forge I haven't but let's speak after
and I'm curious to learn about them and
then I will add it to the to the to the
slides okay thank you so much for your
talk thank you
[Applause]
you